tu n'es quel crétin mais c'est pas de ma
faute j'ai non c'est pas toi qui
chevauchent et le temple de la lune
comme s'il faisait du rodéo le temple de
la lune
chaque gardien a son propre style baba
disons que je me cherche encore
tu sais je encore génial
manifestement tu n'as jamais étudié les
livres anciens ou les lois astronomiques
et tu te prétends gardien sérieux tu as
raison je suis qu'un gain d'un ordinaire
de la forme est ce que je sais faire
c'est calme et les bébés qui font des
cauchemars et c'est lui qui m'a choisi
pas vrai il doit bien y avoir une raison
à ça alors jamais avoir fait une petite
boulette tout à toi c'est la risée de
tout donner
tu vas me le piste d'abord la lune est
même passée soleil six mois tu es devant
nettoyer derrière fois night à kaya sera
la plus con de tout les temps des
gardiens